[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'année 2020 je souhaite une bonne
année est juste aussi je souhaiterais
plus grand des bonheurs et une bonne
santé pour tous pour tous les
génovéfains je souhaite moi ou pour
l'échanger fait la paix dans le monde
je voudrais qu'on fasse des tri sélectif
je souhaite du bonheur à tous les
génovéfains humble choses et de la joie
moins de déchets sur la planète
sourire et être heureux je souhaite du
bonheur du sport et des matchs de foot
je souhaite un prêt pour la période 2020
je voudrais glycation sur les immeubles
et bâtiments pour éviter la pollution
pour 2020 je souhaite aux enfants plus
d'éducation bonne humeur que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école en sorte qu'ils
réussissent dans la vie reprise de
solidarité entre tous les emplois aider
toutes les personnes âgées et
handicapées
votre santé votre liberté et le verbe
être qu'ils soient tous vous
[Musique]